Michael is in Colorado hey Michael
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thank you so much for taking my phone
call sure what's up
hey I'm I am 28 years old and my company
I work for a coal-fired power plant my
company just announced the other day
that by 2030 our plant will be down and
so within ten years I'll be looking for
a new job
I just became debt-free good and thank
you my question you is I was starting to
invest and I was starting to say for a
house since I won't be in this town in
10 years I'm not saving for a house my
question is I make a good amount of
money where I'm at and I was wanting to
know should I maxed out my Roth 401k and
my Roth IRA for the next 10 years
instead of saving for house
what do you make my base salary is 73
grand but I've made a hundred grand the
last so many years what'd you do with
okay I am a scrubber operator I am make
sure that we put a clean air back into
the atmosphere cool and what are you
gonna do I'm gonna try to you know move
into like wind or solar within the same
company within the next ten years but me
being a planner I just want to you know
have the worst-case scenario what town
do you live in I live in a Craig
Colorado
it's a Northwest right by Wyoming and
right by Utah so fairly rule yes Barry
yeah we're we're farmers and coal come
gotcha okay and with the coal plant
shutting down real estate in that area
being the primary employer real estate
in that area is going to struggle a gap
yeah because it's a small town and the
plants closing like it likes I'm not a
movie or something okay so yeah yeah you
don't buy real estate
I agree with you yes I would load my
Roth IRAs my 401ks maxed out I also
would set some money aside that's not in
401ks or Roth IRAs it's just in good
mutual funds for two things or three
things one is for you to retool if you
need to take some classes or whatever in
order for you to have the money to move
and maybe buy a home number two okay and
then number three you could use that
money to start a business in ten years
you might decide not to wait on them to
close you might decide to leave earlier
right exactly
my my Roth IRA is an uh mutual funds
yeah I put all of it in mutual funds but
I want you to have something that's not
in IRAs for your okay for your move for
your reset in your life your education
for your maybe start a business thing so
and to buy a house when you do move and
I'm gonna get out of there sooner rather
than later I don't want this plane
they've announced the plane is going
down I don't really want to ride it all
the way to the ground
exactly yeah I was uh since I made good
money I was gonna see if I could just
you know at least set myself up well for
my next jobs and you know have some
decent retirement by then yeah but also
I mean what would be wrong with making
more money three years from now in a
different career and leaving right
you're exactly right yes you don't have
to sit you don't have to make less money
when you leave if you think this through
you've got a little time there's no
panic here so you can sit here and dream
and say gosh on my second act when the
curtain comes up again after the first
act is closed but the second act I might
want to make 200 a year and I might want
to be in I don't care what you want to
be you just decide and then figure out
what you need to do to go be one of
those and to create a different set of
opportunities or a different set of
things and and then decide where you
want to live in that process
it might be that you stay in energy you
may want to completely backup and
whiteboard your life and just say where
do I go from here hey it's a it's a
pretty cool opportunity you got hey
thanks for the call